und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend historische jahrestage fallen
gerade immer dichter heute wissen wir
dass läuft auf den november hinaus 30
jahrestag des mauerfalls in der
rückschau wirkt das fast zwangsläufig
dabei war es das nicht aber ende
september 89
da war schon viel passiert das
paneuropäische picknick an der grenze
ungarn österreich hatte für 700 ddr
bürger reisefreiheit erzwungen
andere ausreisen auch massen aus reisen
wurden damals noch als einmalige
humanitäre geste verkleidet immer
hilfloser agierten die staatsorgane der
ddr immer mehr löcher zerrissen den
eisernen vor
der moment der unumkehrbarkeit kam am 30
september vom balkon der brd botschaft
in prag
[Applaus]
ja
dass heute ihre ausreise
1 12 voller träume und hoffnungen
tausende ddr flüchtlinge starteten
damals mit sonderzügen in ein neues
leben
heute 30 jahre später reist sie kritisch
zurück in die vergangenheit alles
genauso zum zum heer von der umgebung
wieder fühlt sie sich wie 38 und
durchlebt noch einmal ihre zugfahrt in
die freiheit
damals gesagt wurde hier auch und ihr
drogen zwei jahre hatte die berlinerin
in der ddr auf ihre ausreise gewartet
im herbst 89 plant sie schließlich ihre
flucht kann ich sage sie bananen
vermisster oder irgendwelche sachen habe
ich nicht vermisst habe der freiwillige
zittern begann und nun ist sie
zurückgekehrt da hin wo einst ihrer
reise begann nach prag erstmal nach 30
jahren ich hab da mal so sagen nie
wieder
doch dann kommt die einladung das
jubiläum in der deutschen botschaft zu
feiern sie kritisch ist eine von
mehreren hundert die ihr folgen
momente des wiedersehens und der
erinnerung
die männer mussten dann letztendlich
draußen schlafen im freien auf liegen
selten hat alles nicht mehr recht hat
mit stufen wir haben zutritt in zum
doppelstockbett geschlafen
drei jahrzehnte haben nicht vergessen
lassen warum die menschen all das auf
sich genommen haben
es ist genau die stelle an der sie und
tausend andere den zaun und damit das
ddr-regime überwinden
die leute die schon drin mein name sagt
willkommen in der brd irgendwie wir
haben erstmal sitzen und einfach vor
erschöpfung und vor straße hat man
irgendwie es sollen damals noch zwei
wochen vergehen bis sie kritisch
gewissheit bekommt dass ihre flucht in
der freiheit endet
es kommt der 30 september und hans
dietrich genscher tritt auf den balkon
der botschaft
[Applaus]
wir fahren heute ihre ausreise
manchmal ist es wichtig dass man an die
starken geschichten in der geschichte
erinnert in afghanistan ist es jetzt
bald halb ein uhr nachts die menschen
haben den wahltag hinter sich der
funktionierende demokratie beweisen
sollte vor dem sich aber alle fürchten
mussten
die wahlbeteiligung wird nicht hoch
gewesen sein
wie sollte sie auch wie hoch wäre sie
bei uns wenn an wahllokalen schießereien
und bomben drohen würden
und wenn man wüsste dass es keine echte
wahl gibt wenn es einfach zu viele
hinweise sind auf fälschungen so ist
jede abgegebene stimme heute ein zeichen
für hoffnung und mut vielleicht mut der
verzweiflung es läuft nicht gut in
afghanistan
18 jahre krieg zehntausende von toten
milliardensummen vergeblich
wahrscheinlich kamera florian bericht
fernost routan ist journalistin und
arbeitet beim afghanischen fernsehsender
tolo news in kabul
sie gehört zur jungen generation
afghanischer frauen im büro legt sie
kein kopftuch die wahlen heute bedeuten
ihr sehr viel
wir haben gar keine andere chance als
wählen zu gehen unsere stärken unsere
existenzen der gesellschaft hängen davon
ab
auch andere frauen sind so mutig wie
fahrers dennoch ist ihre wahlbeteiligung
gering viele haben angst vor anschlägen
über 70.000 sicherheitskräfte schützten
die wahlen heute trotzdem gab es
landesweit einige opfer und dutzende
verletzte wie hier in kandahar
besonders die junge generation lässt
sich nicht einschüchtern über 80 prozent
sind jünger als 40 jahre alt ihr votum
könnte wahlentscheidend sein
ich hoffe dass der neue präsident unser
land aus der krise führen kann
und endlich frieden und stabilität
einkehren präsident ashraf ghani konnte
das bisher nicht liefern
der technokrat gilt neben seinem
regierungschef und herausforderer
abdullah abdullah als favorit die bilanz
der regierung ist mäßig jeder zweite
afghane lebt unterhalb der armutsgrenze
die korruption blüht auch jetzt
berichten wahlbeobachter von
unregelmäßigkeiten vielerorts habe es
probleme mit wählerlisten und den
biometrischen maschinen gegeben
viele afghanen wie der maurer nur
muhammad sind frustriert und kriegsmüde
er hat familie und muss sich mit
gelegenheitsjobs über wasser halten
ein präsident muss afghanistan dienen er
muss frieden bringen uns arbeit besorgen
und er sollte sich mit den taliban
verständigen
die taliban aber boykottierten die wahl
sie kontrollieren einschließlich
umkämpfte gebiete insgesamt mehr als die
hälfte des landes friedensverhandlungen
zwischen den usa und den taliban über
einen truppenabzug und einer beteiligung
an der macht sind zuletzt gescheitert
eine neue regierung steht vor der
herausforderung die taliban einzubinden
eine schwierige mission
zum einen erkennen die taliban die
regierung noch gar nicht als
verhandlungspartner an
das heißt da muss erst mal ein
übereinkommen getroffen werden dass man
überhaupt in dialog tritt und dann wird
das ein ganz langer integrationsprozess
im großteil der gesellschaft fürchtet
sich vor den taliban hat angst
freiheitsrechte zu verlieren und da
müssen wirklich parallelgesellschaften
wieder aufeinander zugehen
erste ergebnisse der wahlen werden für
mitte oktober erwartet fahrers traum vom
frieden in afghanistan wird ein
wunschtraum bleiben
nach deutschland nachrichten von gundula
gause beginnen mit sorgen die mancher
gerne hätte der staat kommt mit dem
geldausgeben nicht hinterher ja wurden
des finanzminister scholz hat länder und
kommunen dazu aufgerufen
investitionsmittel in höhe von 15
milliarden euro abzurufen
das geld sei da es müsse nur beantragt
werden aber den letzten jahren stellen
wir fest dass immer weniger es gelingt
dass diese mittel auch abfließen und das
ist ein problem wenn die zeit da ist für
investitionen
scholz kündigte an entwickelt scheidungs
prozesse zu vereinfachen
denn auch städte und gemeinden
kritisieren das vergaberecht und
auflagen immer weiter verschärft worden
seien
die britische regierung will laut
finanzminister david mehr als 18
milliarden euro bereitstellen um bei
einem ungeregelten braig sit das
ausbleiben von eu-geldern auszugleichen
labour-chef corvin brachte sich derweil
für einen möglichen sturz von
premierminister johnson in position
es sei das übliche vorgehen dass bei
einem scheitern der regierung der
oppositionsführer eine
minderheitsregierung bilden
bis neuwahlen abgehalten würden in
washington treiben die us demokraten
ihre untersuchungen für ein mögliches
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen präsident
trump wegen der ukraine affäre voran
drei ausschussvorsitzende forderten
außenminister pompeo unter
strafandrohung zur vorlage von
dokumenten bis freitag auf außerdem
luden sie mehrere diplomaten vor um zu
klären in welchem ausmaß trump die
nationale sicherheit gefährdet habe
indem er die ukraine ende juli in dem
telefonat mit dem neuen präsidenten see
lenski drängte sich in die us wahlen
2020 einzumischen
beim untergang der ostseefähre estonia
heute vor 25 jahren verloren 852
menschen ihr leben der opfer der größten
zivilen schiffskatastrophe der
nachkriegsgeschichte gedachten heute
hinterbliebene und überlebende in der
estnischen hauptstadt tallinn und in
stockholm über 500 der todesopfer waren
stehen bei stürmischer see war die
estonia die 1994 vor der südküste
finnlands sogen
dort liegt sie bis heute auf dem
meeresgrund nur wenige todesopfer
konnten geborgen werden
wahlen in afghanistan
die risse im eisernen vorhang die
nachrichten des tages ergeben heute
abend ein journal über freiheit und
demokratie
letzte station hongkong wo zwei
grundverschiedene jahrestage
aufeinandertreffen der siebzigsten
geburtstag der übermächtigen
volksrepublik wie zur supermacht
aufwächst und der fünfte jahrestag der
regenschirm revolution der erste zivile
aufstand der bürger vor allem der jugend
von hongkong der aufstand der damals im
sande verlief jetzt wieder auferstand
und den sie trotz sich entschlossen am
leben halten
ulf röller ist für uns in hongkong es
war ein seltener moment in dieser sonst
so lauten aufgewühlten stadt eine
schweigeminute in gedenken derer die im
gefängnis sitzen und leiden
oben am himmel kreist schon wieder die
staatsmacht von laserpointern der
demonstranten verfolgt
hellmund schutzmaske als geschenk der
freiheitskampf in hongkong nach drei
monaten dauer einsatz hat seine routine
ich verteile die ausrüstung weil ich
will dass die menschen geschützt sind
die polizei ist so brutal auf den
demonstrationen heute zeigen sie die
bilder von der regenschirm bewegung vor
fünf jahren damals forderte hongkong
schon einmal die machthaber in peking
heraus und scheiterte aber diesmal soll
alles anders werden
nicht nur die jugend alle gehen auf die
straße es ist eine bürgerbewegung das
ist der unterschied
die leute sind heute viel wütender auf
der regierung als damals die jugend
treibt die jetzigen proteste vor an
unterstützt von großen teilen der
gesellschaft ohne anführer ist diese
bewegung wild und unberechenbar in den
nächten knallt es ein freiheitskampf bei
dem viel gekämpft wird
wir wollen dass die chinesische
regierung versteht dass wir niemals
aufgeben
sie müssen unsere forderungen erfüllt
die chinesische regierung versteht nicht
sie probt in diesen tagen unaufhörlich
ihre eigene herrlichkeit machtbewusst
bereitete die feiern zum 70 jahrestag
der gründung der volksrepublik vor
viele hongkonger haben eine eigene sicht
auf chinas geschichte geprägt es sie von
unterdrückung und unmenschlichkeit
sie sehen der supermacht die reiche
gnadenlose diktatur
dies ist typisch chinesische taktik sie
machen die länder wirtschaftlich
abhängig und dann versuchen sie dich zu
erpressen und ein politisches system zu
ändern
die musikerin denise ho hat schon bei
den protesten vor fünf jahren mitgemacht
heute weiß sie hongkong braucht hilfe um
gegen das mächtige china zu bestehen sie
hat eine ganz einfache botschaft an uns
alle
es geht die ganze welt an nicht nur
china und hongkong
wir alle müssen auf beginn wir an
hongkongs seite ein großer wunsch in
einer welt die auf gefühle und hoffnung
oft keine rücksicht nimmt
dresden feiert die wiedereröffnung der
königlichen parade räume im
residenzschloss knapp 75 jahre nach
ihrer zerstörung im zweiten weltkrieg
bis ins kleinste detail wurden die
barocken räume rekonstruiert 300
handwerksbetriebe aus ganz europa waren
beteiligt was an originalen teilen noch
vorhanden war
wie dieser gold py laster wurde
integriert der legendäre sächsische
kurfürst august der starke hatte die
paraderäume 1719 einrichten lassen und
die lottozahlen an diesem samstag lauten
wie immer ohne gewähr 13 24 27 30 43 44
superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text das wetter
wird nun unbeständig und herbstlich
morgen gibt es im norden dunkle wolken
kräftige regengüsse und stürmische winde
im süden bleibt das noch überwiegend
sonnig bei 14 bis 25 grad
die kommenden tage werden sehr
wechselhaft und windig es gibt häufig
schauer und gewitter bis dienstag ist es
mild und danach würde es deutlich kühler
morgen wählt österreich schon wieder ein
parlament und damit die nächste
regierung am abend wird die spannende
frage sein ob es nur die nächste ist
oder eine neue bis dann spannende
unterhaltung beim sport gleich mit sven
voss
[Musik]